my uncle is though is time and place is
something that he really doesn't
understand this fool is like trying to
crack jokes at my grandma's funeral not
even a [ __ ] joke dude this guy's just
as my grandma is being put into the
grave he goes as he's looking at this
mechanism that's putting her in the
grave he goes that's pretty handy huh I
just see it side by cuz it go dead shut
the [ __ ] up okay so mad dude that's how
some people cope yeah
my roommate right his brother he copes
with comedy a lot so like their their
grandpa I think there was a ills a
grandpa's funeral right and it was
really sad and shitty and yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] up and so it was his
grandpa's funeral his dad it was his
turn to go see his father so he goes up
to his casket my friend's brother goes
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what do they talk about afterwards good
you know what a good idea idea what this
episode started off so sad what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude my wildest dreams I
would never ever think about division
but he's always pranking and [ __ ] the
whole congregation should have beat his
ass Bob Bob is dying laughing it was